when people said donald trump was
anti-press
he had the power of the executive i was
actually disappointed that donald trump
didn't do more on section 230 didn't do
anything to actually get anybody oh yeah
he revoked some people's press pass
because they asked some dishonest
questions for a day and a half think
about it i don't want if there's a
republican in power i want that that
potential tyranny regardless of who's
willing that power to have some checks
and balances this is just as much for
future liberals because i don't want
them to be removed from the platform
outside of criminality meaning actually
calling for violence or physical harm to
people right these are things that we
have laws for these things um
this is just as much for for liberals as
it is for conservatives it's just really
hard for liberals right now to see that
because they even even though donald
trump was president for four years and
even during that time they see
themselves as the ones in power because
you have really
three to five companies who are more
powerful than any national government
that has ever existed in the world
before today and that's facebook twitter
alphabet apple amazon
my guest this week is the
self-proclaimed strangest animal of talk
radio and the host of louder with
crowder stephen crowder welcome to the
show
thank you very much for well i don't
proclaim that that's gowan's song but i
appreciate you attributing that lofty
praise so i'll take it i was told it was
self-proclaimed we do some serious
research around here you've just allowed
it to become part of the lore
yeah exactly i've allowed it and it's i
don't even think we have the rights to
the music but i appreciate that you know
you started off as a comedian as did i
yet you do actual research and i feel
compelled to whereas a lot of other
media half the time i'm going like what
are none of you going to fact check this
why am i the one to do this and i see
you doing that a lot too so regardless
of politics you know i appreciate it
yeah well that is going to be sort of
the thrust of everything we talk about
for the next hour because yes whether we
agree on everything or not is irrelevant
but i know you do do your research and
you've fact checked a lot of things that
i see in the media that are nonsense and
you do a great job with it which is why
i wanted to have you on and i've been on
your show and we're going to do a little
something for you after uh this is this
is cross promotion palooza wait do a
little something for me after all people
listening he's going to come on the show
it doesn't have anything to do with his
queer party friends no yeah no none of
that kind of stuff it's going to we're
on skype but everyone's gonna stay
closed okay let's start here so crowder
uh i know a little bit about your
history but for the for the people that
know nothing about you uh first off you
are in uh you're in michigan right now
is that correct no let's not talk about
it uh my show is based out of michigan i
don't need my whereabouts disclosed can
we oh gosh there's a problem with live
television um yeah i was i was born in
detroit raised in montreal and so i
started acting at a young age 12 years
old was doing voice work and tv and
started doing stand-up in my mid-teens
which then brought me to new york la as
soon as i was old enough to be in a bar
in the states and uh kind of came full
circle i was a young libertarian sort of
edgy i guess considered comic getting
banned from clubs and colleges and then
went to the internet and then here we
are but yeah it all started out was
raised in montreal acting stand up that
was my bread and butter really up until
i was pulled into this political arena
at uh i want to say 21 at fox news yeah
you know it's funny i also feel like i
was sort of pulled into this i've always
loved politics and i studied politics in
college but in this recent incarnation
in the last couple years i do feel like
there's there's this pull uh whether
whether i like it or not um but so were
you always into politics you were you
were getting banned at clubs what were
you doing yeah colleges um well there
was like i remember the first thing was
a multicultural fair and muslims
complained and this was long before
ahmed the dead terrorist or any of that
you know if you watch i've done plenty
of material on islam and i've made fun
of
literally every single group or
politician on our program particularly
people subscribe to the podcast our
commercials are nothing but sketches and
parodies and so everyone no no one is
safe there
i just made a joke about some kind of
like a muslim guy beating his wife i
don't remember what it was i might have
been 17 at the time beating his wife
in order to keep quiet about the fact
that he beat her and people got offended
and then asians got offended because i
had some jokes about anime i remember
being young just thinking this is this
is comedy right like some other guy just
got up talking about a a three-way at a
truck stop and my stuff is relatively
benign it's it's offensive but it's not
dirty so it started with that and then
just meetings and back rooms you know
with viacom and mtv and and people
saying you really shouldn't be saying
this um so it just sort of happened
organically i was always conservative
because i was raised in a socialist
province um my parents were you know
like my dad is that me that's how you do
it yeah yes well you know what and
that's true a lot of people don't
understand if you talk to people who've
left those places very very few of them
still support socialism
people who are in it who don't know any
better you'll probably get a lot of
canadians who like their free health
care but once you have canadians who've
experienced the quality of american
health care
at best you'll get them saying yeah the
quality is better here but i still like
the safety net of canada so it started
with me as a kid you know at 12 years
old 13 years old making pretty
significant checks doing this show
arthur at pbs i got to meet garfunkel uh
when i was there and i was during his
phase where we were coached do not
mention paul simon so
i'm a 13 year old kid like listen are
garfunkel's coming in don't ever say the
name paul simon and uh anyway so
no it's not easy i mean what did you you
really didn't do a lot without the simon
and my dad explained to me listen this
is your check 52 is going to be gone for
ren went down a list and as a kid but
you know that's my money i still have to
make up the time i left school to go to
the studio
and uh so it developed pretty
organically and i do attribute it to a
good dad you know even though you and
him would disagree on a lot um he he
always encouraged me to answer questions
and think critically he didn't say
you're a conservative you're a christian
say why do you believe this and you know
substantiate your claim and uh so there
was no moment of genius it just sort of
happened that way yeah and i know you
know this but i i love talking to people
that i would disagree with i'd rather
talk to people that i would disagree
with but someone that's coming from a
principled place so like you for example
i mean i've seen you do things that many
of my friends
on the left would say are incredibly
offensive things things about trans
people or handicapped people or muslims
or whatever else but to me your style is
sort of more the seth macfarlane family
guy style which is we literally make fun
of everyone period and that's sort of
the egalitarian way of comedy that it
should be done i think
yeah i don't i don't what have i done
about handicapped people i can't i mean
we have i'm sure i have no doubt but you
did the you were in the wheelchair uh no
i actually had knee surgery oh that was
i thought well i know you had knee
surgery but i thought that was part of
me no that was legitimate that was that
was legitimate yeah the journey for
bernie no actually a knee surgery
um and but now what you really you
really take comedy far that you go ahead
and have knee surgery just for the bit
that's commitment
it is it is commit well that was
commitment that was a journey for bernie
where jean guitar went in for nine hours
at a bernie rally i mean you know at the
end of the day it's either funny or it's
not and i know you'll get people in the
con comments section go this is why
conservatives can't be funny i've never
been a vet school i think jon stewart is
hilarious one of my favorite comedians
is kathleen madigan
i think bill maher
it can be so horrendously unfunny it's
unwatchable because all he does is throw
up his hands and make a political
statement there's nothing wrong with
that right right all these teabaggers
and everyone like let's just hack to me
sorry he can be funny but when he does
that you just need to say okay your
comedy hat is off um and i do have like
you do give them more leeway than people
who don't claim to be comedians but it
has to be funny and i do think and i
wrote about this at big hollywood back
when i was you know andrew andrew
breitbart was a good friend before it
was breitbart um shapiro myself adam
baldwin some of the first writers and i
read about the tina fey doctrine i said
there's been a noticeable shift in
comedy and if you'll see this on snl
where tina fey will forgo the funny joke
deliberately to push an agenda and she
did that with palin and mccain during
that election cycle and it just it just
wasn't funny
and that's my biggest issue with it
again not that you can't do it you can
do it just be honest about it i tell
people all the time yeah i'm pretty
biased and every now and then i'm going
to use my platform to push an agenda
that i agree with and if i could take
koch brother money i'd have it on a
flavor flav necklace with a spinning k
clock i would be gaudy about it i wish i
had all the special interest money
people claim that i do i don't but i
would take it if i could all of these
bad ideas that have now infected all of
these companies they're in direct combat
or conflict with reality so when you say
that there are biological differences
between men and women which everyone
knows to be true every biologist knows
that to be true but that doesn't fit in
with the sjw thing that these companies
have now put into their terms of service
they've put into the way they behave
with their boards and everywhere else
it's almost like this this is a totally
intractable
problem because their reality actually
is different than the reality that we've
known for thousands of years you know
what's funny though is actually i will
say this with the and the people say why
do you focus on the trans issue so much
well i will say this because as a
christian conservative i believe when
you say that there that that uh there is
no fundamental difference at all between
men and women that men and women are
completely interchangeable i think
that's a real problem for our
civilization i think it's a real it's a
real problem if we're not saying that
hey there are moms there are dads there
are boys there are girls because you
raise them differently not only that you
support them differently as a community
you find out how to help them
differently but i will say this there is
something kind of funny we were talking
about this earlier on on my program this
morning
about how things that you would say
would be considered
toxically masculine or patriarchal or be
considered anti-woman uh unless
it's trans so for example you know the
55 year old the 50 year old man who's
playing college basketball in the girls
league or fallon fox
who lived as a man and fathered children
into his 30s and then you know beat up
women identifying as a female when you
read their stories what they say is you
know what when i came when i came out to
my teammates you're six foot eight 245
pounds by the way i think i don't think
that i think they deserve an academy
award if you think you were coming out
but they said my teammates never knew
this i was just reading this today on
air my teammates never knew this because
my level of endurance
strength my lung capacity i was the same
as other women well hold on a second
what are you implying there or if you
look at a lot of the times what a trans
male to female is well it's really
perpetuation of these unrealistic beauty
standards it's usually someone dressing
like a barbie with a blonde wig and
over-the-top makeup right and usually
they end up getting uh breast implants
these are things that are thought of as
toxic masculine stereotypes until you
say well i'm trans and people didn't
know because i'm weaker i'm smaller i'm
slower i don't have the same lung
capacity but look at my blonde wig and
makeup right that's what a woman is it
distills both sexes to the stereotypes
that we're supposed to reject only now
we have to embrace as a part of this
very very new by the way uh sort of
gender experiment and i think that
that's also really important as it
relates to the speech guidelines online
because when you effectively are saying
that half of the medical community are
not allowed to voice an opinion that the
your rules are being applied equally
then i just disagree as to what equally
means and then of course we get back to
the idea of facebook where they don't
even say what what it is we still have
no wha wha what what happened with the
stream was it gone it's gone just give
me an answer and dave on that point i
mean when you look at the rules
themselves and the way they've been set
out even the very basic statement of
saying you know we won't allow hate or
harassment based on race religion
political ideology
and you say okay so you're not allowed
to make fun of white male christians
okay got it all right is that is that
wait do they say political ideology i'd
be shocked if that was in there so they
used to say political ideology and then
in 2016 they actually gave statements to
the senate saying we don't actually do
it and that was the thing that they
trumpeted everywhere because it wasn't
in their particular rules but they were
being called out about it and they said
no no no no no in case anyone is
concerned we do not do that i mean it's
in the response letter it's in their
articles multiple spokespersons said we
do not do that and that is the thing
that they have advertised ever since and
they even say it now you have mark
zuckerberg saying no senator we do not
engage in any kind of ideological you
know considerations we do not suppress
conservatives and i'm not saying they
suppress every single conservative no
that's not that's not a hill anyone
needs to die on it's a question about
individual voices and what they're doing
and the rules as they have them but how
do you define these things they can't
define them and yet in the end the
creators are the ones that are abused
because of it and by the way this is
just as much for liberals as it is for
conservatives i mean keep in mind look
this is something also to consider
when people said donald trump was
anti-press
he had the power of the executive i was
actually disappointed that donald trump
didn't do more on section 230. didn't do
anything to actually get anybody oh yeah
he revoked some people's press pass
because they asked some dishonest
questions for a day and a half think
about it i don't want if there's a
republican in power i want that that
potential tyranny regardless of who's
willing that power to have some checks
and balances this is just as much for
future liberals because i don't want
them to be removed from the platform
outside of criminality meaning actually
calling for violence or physical harm to
people right these are things that we
have laws for these things um
this is just as much for for liberals as
it is for conservatives it's just really
hard for liberals right now to see that
because they even even though donald
trump was president for four years and
even during that time they see
themselves as the ones in power because
you have really
three to five companies who are more
powerful than any national government
that has ever existed in the world
before today and that's facebook twitter
alphabet apple amazon so does that worry
you or does that push your your
libertarian stuff to to the end because
i mean you know my i agree with you on
that and it's like if you're breaking
the laws of the united states then you
got a bigger problem than the platforms
because then the government's going to
go after you so that should clean up
most of that
um but but you hear you know there were
all these conservatives saying oh trump
had to do something trump had do
something and now i still hear some of
them saying it but it's like wait a
minute i thought you hate biden so now
you want the government involved even
though it's not your guy anymore like it
sort of just basically flipped
everybody's beliefs on top of themselves
my position has always been very
consistent whereas i just want the first
step is them deciding i want them to
publicly declare if they're a platform
if they want to be treated as such or a
publisher because they're kind of
benefiting from both sets of rules right
now and you have to pick one right
either you are liable for the kind of
content on your platform in which case
you can take these uh for you can take
these actions which they take which act
uh beyond the law and in some cases by
the way don't even follow the law
because there's a different set of
online law to give you an idea here um
you know we had it for a long time in
this country okay uh an idea of what
investigative journalism was that no
longer exists
it no longer exists because first off we
have single party consent laws youtube
and facebook don't necessarily follow
those laws so you can say okay we're
finding someone who's a corrupt member
of congress or you know a senator or
running for president for example and uh
we're in a single party consent state
which means that legally i have the
right to record this conversation and i
catch them in an act that is
deliberately harmful right that is
deliberately manipulative something like
that i mean for example the access
hollywood tape you can follow all these
laws and it can be removed because
youtube says they want to it can be
removed as we've seen on the same day
from youtube facebook twitter even
though you followed the laws and then if
you've broken the laws it can be allowed
to stay up
that is a very very scary thing we've
had this happen where we've interviewed
people on the street right where we've
and we were already in single party
consent states where we had the right to
interview people but had them sign
release forms to be on air with these
questions and then youtube said actually
this someone said this was a violation
of privacy so this is a public protest
well there's no reasonable expectation
of privacy and by the way we have them
if we want us to send you the form we
have them on camera confirming and
consenting they say it doesn't matter
because now the rule is if anyone ever
regrets being on camera we're going to
remove it well how wonderful that would
have been for nixon how wonderful for
anthony weiner
investigative journalism doesn't exist
anymore and that is scary because these
people can effectively create the laws
and that determines what you what you
can and can't see and it determines who
and who is never held accountable but i
want to be really clear because there
are a lot of people who who sort of you
know get by on on social media drama and
it's there's a throttling and there's a
counter claim look we've had false
copyright claims we've never lost on
those right half asian lawyer bill
richmond we've filed counter claims
we've had to file petitions of
information in the past
this is very different this is the big
one we filed an official notice uh uh
that we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate motion for um
an injunction in conjunctive relief
because we have two strikes in our
account right now
uh and we have good reason to believe
that there may be a third one that
they're looking for how do i know this
because they're just waiting well we
right and because it's not very clear
i should say it is very clear that we
didn't violate specific policies uh and
so they said well maybe the totality of
it in tandem so if people want to know
and by the way people can still watch us
uh we're available at mug club you know
in blaze lotto credit.com mug club and
we always recommend that people join
anyways because there's an hour
worth of extra content every day but
we're still making sure that the free
content is available on apple on android
spotify and right now on rumble though
we can't stream live it's a little
glitchy we're working with them but um
you know the issue here with youtube to
give an idea on a couple of strikes the
first one that came in was
a warning that was supposed to be a
heart strike uh on uh voter fraud now i
have never said that uh donald trump won
the election that the ghost of hugo
chavez you know ring rigged smartmatic
uh and and whisked away wisconsin uh but
just like amy klobuchar just like
elizabeth warren just like jimmy carter
i said that individual voter fraud does
occur and of course as they said it
occurs far more with mass mail and
voting uh just because there are fewer
checks and balances there are fewer ways
to sort of verify and so the segment
that we did was almost comical in us
saying you know not that there's
anything wrong with that thing not that
there's any vote fraud but we
cross-reference voter rolls with
addresses that didn't exist on google
earth sent interns with a copy of that
day's paper at an empty lot
on camera live to say look we know that
it occurs
i think it might have been 30 or 40
addresses they said that's a violation
of the election fraud policy
okay the second one was wait can i pause
you there because i think just sort of
philosophically and i don't want to get
myself booted now too but right we're
not even addressing the philosophical
issue which is should you be allowed to
just say what you want to say in a free
country right you know a supposedly open
platform and everything else i mean it's
just worth mentioning that that
you're saying you didn't break the rules
but the pr the question really is are
the rules just completely insane no
absolutely and by the way we were never
told that we were wrong too to be clear
no one is no one has proven matter of
fact we got fact checked and some people
said that we were wrong when really the
fact check ended up being they changed
the voter rolls the the next night to a
new address that didn't exist that was
one that was part of a series so i don't
want to get too off into the weeds there
but these were things where we did our
due diligence to a comical degree that
was the point of this segment the first
actual strike i believe i don't remember
the exact sequence was covid 15 uh 15
days to flatten the curve a one year
anniversary
now what did we do we showed them cdc
saying don't wear masks they wear masks
don't wear double mask wear double mask
we won't have a vaccine in a year i
wouldn't take the vaccine if it was done
in a year take the vaccine all of this
stuff right which is really tough to
navigate as an american from what i
understand the statement that was a
violation
was something to be effective because i
don't want you to get booted something
to the effect of
the covet is significantly more lethal
to old people we know that we need to
figure out how to protect the most
vulnerable but for some reason due to
the immune response according to the cdc
and we always list our references
available on our website
young people
are significantly less at risk of death
from kova than the flu for some reason
young but old people it's way more
deadly we use the cdc mortality tables
we've been given a specific reason as to
what the violation is but the time code
that i believe we were given was where
that statement was made and people can
we're the only show i know of if you go
to lydewithcrowder.com every single
episode has a page with the references
the references for that statement were
the cdc and world health organization
now some people can say well you're
making it seem like it's not as big of
it people may not take it seriously well
a that's not what i'm saying and b if
we're going to follow the science it's
important to understand how different
immune systems respond to a novel virus
it's important that you don't tell
people shut up if they have a problem
with a two-year-old wearing a mask if
you say well hold on a second we don't
have two or four year olds wear a mask
for the flu where there are
significantly more deaths for younger
people it is significant significantly
deadlier for older people or the
immunocompromised you're not allowed to
discuss that the most recent one this is
the second strike here this is why
there's a lawsuit which i really didn't
want this to have to come to i would
just want to do the show uh is when
i was recently celebrating actually
praising the officer who saved that
young girl's life who was about to be
stabbed by mackay brian i said not only
is that justified from the police i
believe it's necessary because if the
police cannot shoot someone who is in
the process of attempting to stab you
then we might as well not have police
and i believe that we should have police
that was considered bullying harassment
but not technically but the totality may
be over time indicative of bullying
harassing by supporting the police who
is that bullying who are you bullying by
saying that you supported the cops
saving a woman's life who was about to
be decapitated who is that bullying
apparently it might be considered
reveling in in the death of makai bryant
i don't know we don't have an official
answer and we can't get these official
answers from people at youtube but let
me just be really clear with people out
there
this is tantamount to saying to everyone
out there
if you're conservative we don't want you
look if they are saying hey look you
cannot discuss the mortality rates of
coba you cannot point out that the cdc
has been inconsistent and confusing
which has made it harder for americans
to stay safe you are not allowed to say
that voter fraud has ever occurred
to any degree and you are not allowed to
support police if they save someone's
life mid-stabbing if the person
committing the stabbing happens to be a
girl of color that is saying you are not
welcome on this platform if you hold
these views now if they say that that's
fine the issue there is i'm pro-business
i'm anti-fraud youtube says all views
are welcome
those strikes without description tell
us otherwise we need to know the rule
book because people's livelihoods depend
on it well crowder you know last week i
put up an interview with david horowitz
i'm sure you know david horowitz and
i've never in in all of my years of
doing this show i've never edited for
content except one time i had a guest
come on who was drunk and stoned and we
ended up editing the just to basically
save this person's career it's the only
time we've edited for i did that once
too we can compare notes off there
this person was doing crack in the
laundry room no joke yeah he was
probably the same person but uh but last
week for the first time we edited for
content because david horowitz a free
man in what i thought was a free country
dared to say two sentences that i knew
my channel could be deleted
like that so we had to we censored it on
youtube i mean simple as that i put it
up in my locals community but now i'm
having you you crazy right wing maniac
well you're such a tease i know i want
to hear the two sentences and that's the
issue right what's going to happen is of
course all people want to hear are the
sentences and they assume that it's like
not seeing the monster in a scary movie
you assume that it's worse than it is
that's how you radicalize people when
you see these new york times articles
saying hey radicalization and it has a
picture with me next to philip defranco
and then by the way hey he [ __ ]
i was in there come on were you in there
too
that's right yeah i just you know again
i would never imagine that you would be
in there radicalizing people dave reuben
but what happens is then they complain
about echo chambers right well look
what's more radical a view of someone
who believes what the guy who believes
in a flat tax
or the people who believe in 90 income
tax the guy who believes that police
need to be demilitarized to a degree but
that they also need to be able to do
their job and they should wear body cams
or the people who believe we should have
no police whatsoever we should have no
prisons whatsoever like rashida taleb
like aoc like these people believe this
is not a radical point of view this the
reason for this lawsuit is
look you know could i uh
at some point sail off under the sunset
with support from people at mud club i
don't know further but at some point i
could but what about the next kid
who wants to start a business you know i
started this in 2009 maybe 2008 with a
blue bed sheet behind me
i don't see a world in which their point
of view is even allowed to be expressed
and we talk about othering people
youtube is othering an entire half of
the country and by the way
more than 80 of black people while we're
talking about the mackay bryant and that
officer situation more than 80 of black
people want at least as much of a police
presence as exists now if not more and
because that isn't a view that is
permissible on we silence these
minorities too we host people under look
if the guy who did change my mind which
was antithetical to the you know sort of
24-hour news cycle if it bleeds it leads
if that's removed as impermissible
no conservative viewpoint is permissible
on youtube it's my favorite gay wasp
gay jew i guess uh but that we have to
be careful with the terminology uh you
can follow him on the twitter reuben
report and you can follow him on youtube
youtube.com ruben report for as long as
he's allowed to still be there dave
rubin how are you sir
well first off crowder uh a lot of
people right now a lot of people telling
me that you're a homophobe yes uh that
that's word out on the street now of
course a phobe is a phobia a phobia is
an irrational fear so i thought even
though you're interviewing me here i
would ask you the first question do you
have an irrational fear of gay people
like if a gay person is saying walking
down the street and you're walking this
way do you freak out like you know like
is this yourself is this going to lead
to you telling everybody that i hugged
you again and you tried to embarrass me
and ruin my street credit one time
and you did get a very very warm
uncomfortably long hug ah okay well that
always feels great coming from a man who
typically likes hugs uh for men uh but
uh so he's by the way how
irrational fear because people are going
to be angry just that i'm even talking
to you right now you deny my existence
crowder you're you're coming for gay
people even though you're dressed like a
member of the village people what the
hell is going on here
this is so deep irrational for me this
is if alanis morris said we're at it as
a member i you know i don't necessarily
think so but um
um
you know i don't like the parties they
get a little bit loud i lived in chelsea
for a year and it was a little bit tough
to find sleep i'm not gonna lie i was
irritated
that's what it is so you look for
chelsea just like at one time was really
like the gayest place in new york i'm
not sure if it still is anymore i think
maybe that's hell's kitchen or out here
we have west hollywood and i think a lot
of what happens with you and the gays is
you do have a little ptsd from living in
chelsea where there's a lot of parties
it's very loud there's people screaming
and having good time they they have
something called sunday fun day i've
never had that fun on a sunday we just
call it the sabbath
yeah well i can't have that much fun
during the day
fun from about 8 p.m to about 10 p.m
that's pretty much it for me yeah by the
way how yeah so how offended were you
with the uh apology because we're like
man reuben is pissed that you made the
rock hudson gomer pile a bit and i'm
like well okay well i didn't think the
joke itself was that great i would have
appreciated a golden girl's reference
you know blanche's brother clayton was a
very straight acting gay guy i would
have preferred that that would have
worked a little more comedically for me
yes but uh but you're doing the right
thing here man you cannot bow to these
people and you know it's not a
coincidence that the same guy that's
going after you i don't even need to
mention his name but if you want it you
can the same box guy that's going after
the uh gentleman and scholar from vox of
latino origin who happens to be uh
attracted to members of the same sex
which is both beautiful and brave yes
continue yes let's say well i don't care
i don't care what his ethnicity is i
don't care what his gender is i i don't
care and about any of those immutable
characteristics what i care is about
what someone does with their life and in
this case this is the same guy the same
guy now going after you and trying to
take down your channel and making a
whole hullabaloo about it this is the
same guy that a couple weeks ago i think
you know this i was trying to get uh
pete bootage on the show tweeted at uh
tweeted at pete butterjudge his
immediately his pr press people say dm
me i get it you know the head of uh pr
for him he says dm start going back and
forth we trade some emails he's got a
trip coming to june in uh coming to l.a
in june we're going to work it out and
then next thing you know this guy and a
huffington post journalist and media
matters the ceo president of media
matters all jump in to start the mob
attacking the press guy of mayor pete so
that he won't do my show and then they
just stopped responding what was their
reasoning
well i'm a scary dude i was gonna say
like here's the one thing if anything
the only valid criticism i would say of
you is that you you tend to be very nice
with everybody like you i don't think
i've ever seen you getting somebody's
grill i would love to see that
isn't it funny crowder that we live in a
time where everybody's always upset that
everybody hates each other right
everyone's trying to destroy each other
we're more polarized than ever before i
mean these are all just the things
people say right then i come around and
i really i have treated you included i
have treated every single one of my
guests you act as though i should have
been the exception to that rule but yes
you were the one i thought about doing
differently but but truly i
every single one of my guests exactly
the same whether i've had bishop baron
in here from the archdiocese in my own
home where i lived with my husband and
he's obviously not for gay marriage i
treated him with the exact amount of
respect that i've treated any of my
lefty guests that i would treat any
libertarian or any progressive with i
treat everybody exactly the same and
that's partly why i'm taking the hits
right now because they re it's one thing
to go after you because it's like you're
saying i'm a conservative i'm using
comedy to really throw it in their face
sure where me like they don't know what
to do with me because if you look if it
was the back of a baseball card they'd
be like wait a minute this guy's
supposed to be a lefty he acts nice you
know he lives in l.a none of this adds
up so that's why a certain amount of
hate is coming to me but by the way you
know this fox journalist um and again i
i don't i don't even i can't i'm not
even sure what his name is carlos
something gentlemen scholar latino
origin same-sex attraction wonderful
beautiful brief yeah
in his uh twitter bio it says that
tucker carlson is a white supremacist
yeah yeah now that seems pretty freaking
directly hateful directly uh potentially
inciting violence like to be a white
supremacist well it's not especially
when you see that he didn't potentially
incite he said milkshake he said assault
commit battery against white
supremacists and has identified people
yeah so it's that's not left to the
imagination there's like we wouldn't
call it foreshadowing if this were an
auteur he'd like oh he's a violent guy
right so think about what this guy's
doing i mean we have three examples now
so he's trying to stop people from
talking to me as an interviewer no
matter how moderate i may be he's trying
to literally get you booted off youtube
and he's putting messaging out there as
a journalist and i've got air quotes
going uh that tucker carlson is a white
supremacist so this is what this is why
journalism is collapsing this sucks on
the youtube front i mean they've been
crushing my channel even worse than
yours and it's like you know we just
gotta we gotta keep fighting man what
else can we do right i don't know if
i've been crushing you worse than us uh
you know do you ever think that maybe
the criticism lobbed against you that is
that you are very articulate you're very
nice but sometimes you you use
expressions that would sound like a
1940s homophobe like see those two good
time boys with the hullabaloo see
it's very it's a little confusing for a
criticism of you no it's a christian you
said hullabaloo the hullabaloo these
kids with their hooting nannies um
a little older than you i am 40 i'll be
43 in a couple weeks so really you carry
it well that's that's the one thing with
being lighter you know being overall uh
you're you're smaller than i am have
heavy heavy weights don't age well
there's a lot of torque on the joints um
no no you're not aging well everyone no
everyone knows that i'm not aging well
like even dylan
picking you off youtube it's the fact
that you're aging horribly yes exactly
like a paddling from dark crystal not
quite as bad as don lemon but um he just
didn't get the gene he didn't get the
the anti-aging day jeans i don't know
what it is with donald you just see just
the luck of the draw if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell